Oh
[ __ ] I'm sorry for not speaking much but
seriously I'm so [ __ ] focused
the barrel contains less than half had
all right I got some oil
what is this
I want something useful
it's gotta be something
what a psycho supposed to do I was
supposed to collect chemistry I thought
I was chemistry stuff
oh wait here's something
oh oh oh oh no oh God oh [ __ ]
don't be such a [ __ ] [ __ ] already
come on I can do this okay it's fine
that did not just blow out god damn it
so I got the kalam ID
and I thought there was like for stuff I
was gonna collect and I think I
collected okay I think I collected like
other selves [ __ ] Oh
I see trace goddamnit I don't like
traces
uh-huh I'm supposed to push these
somewhere
see where the end of these trees leads
here
let's lit this up
[ __ ] that everything just had to go I
just waited wasted so many
am I supposed to wait I think I just saw
something
what was it
maybe it's a graphic book
how's my son doing [ __ ] not well
I was suppose to do I'm confused
can't think straight
what's up with this trace
oh wait [ __ ] I'm so [ __ ] I'm just
supposed to use these to get up right
get up there
is that it
No
I thought so
oh wait I can push this away Oh extra
push
maybe I can crash that's nah I'm just
gonna try there
huh
I need to waste that right now
all right I think we're good now
you see out there
okay I got my stuff I don't know what
more I should collective if I don't know
if I'm like done here or what I thought
that worse for chemicals suck I was
gonna collect
I'm kind
what just happened
nope not going in there nope
Jesus Christ
but I feel like I have to it's only
place I haven't been there can I save
something and then just
oh well that's great
why not come on sure it's nothing
hello oh well that's perfect because I
love me some [ __ ] me
uh-huh
nope okay
okay
acceptance same [ __ ] pinions as usual
well at least I know we're on the right
track now which feels good I was kind of
confused there for a while let's head in
here and yeah he's definitely up there
[ __ ] douchebag scaring the crap out
of me okay so we got the let's lift this
up and this mine my name Williams last
words my name is William House of Gary
these are my final words my confession
and testament two years ago I was
summoned to the castle of Brandenburg
which is this castle in case you didn't
realize as most of their eres tu cres
Cressy I was curious about what this
supposed knight of the order could want
from me and accepted the invitation the
Baron was friendly and a PO offered me a
proposed proposition it dawned on me
that the nature of the contract was
sordid and that the reason I was chosen
was because of my foolish follies of my
past and not the honors I've been
rewarded during my time as a soldiers
yeah I know I'm not the best reader I'm
not American or English or anything okay
continuing I was to kidnap healthy
humans upon his slightest whim and do so
without asking questions in return he
would attest to my character at the
royal court advancing
my position within noble society I would
like to claim that I struggled with my
decision but it came swiftly and I
accepted the wholeheartedly ever since
that day I've brought men women and
children oh wait sorry didn't finish
reading it iris
there we go and children to brennenburg
I can't remember the numbers oh jeez
what there were but there were many
perhaps even hunt holy crap none of the
of whom we were ever seen or heard from
again
tonight the Baron invited me and my man
down to the wine cellar to celebrate our
work I had my suspicious dance as we
descended that stairs but he insisted
and joined us in a toast the wine tasted
fine and my men had drank without
restraint so begins the punishments for
our sins the Baron has locked us up and
returned upstairs forgive me for what I
have done I was weak and fell into
diabolic ways my men are screaming their
skins has been pierced by their own
tangled bones I feel my incites revolt
excuse me against their god-given nature
blood has began to par for from our eyes
and I can no longer Wow that's it's not
very nice I feel bad for him and we got
our aqua regia aquarius is only one left
then I would assume I'm not sure why the
hell I would want to create artificial
life but apparently that's something I
need to do
I'm not sure where I can find it though
it's kind of confusing
because I thought I this was like the
last room or it's not something maybe
it's in here nope
all right that just means something
really really really really creepy is
gonna happen
[ __ ] great just what I needed
[ __ ]
all right take it easy now you can do
this pity you're a man
you're [ __ ] alpha let's [ __ ] do
this
huh
have enough meaning here I don't
remember
yeah yeah
yeah I've been in here obviously
otherwise this wouldn't have been licked
then I went in here
I'm confused now
Wow I'm
this is so confusing
I hate it so much don't tell me I have
to go upstairs don't [ __ ] tell me
that I know he is up there oh well I
guess it's time to man up
and face your [ __ ] fears all right
but I thought I
you need equi for this doesn't make any
sense I'm gonna just gonna run through
the rims once more to see if I haven't
missed anything
No
oh yeah collect that there
that are basically 3d and I'm out of all
s [ __ ] great
I gotta be something here
what is this No
maybe I'll ready gather it before
without even noticing I remember now
that was the chemistry part I picked up
huh
this is weird and confusing
all right I guess oh it's a [ __ ]
shame
I should refill my oil I don't have much
left but let's just do it anyway
I guess we're gonna move up then I guess
there are four door store those I feel
like they should be something that I've
missed being in there I've been in there
I've been in others five doors
should be something here why is there
not something here
are they